an investigation is underway this
morning after at least 27 migrants died
when their small boat capsized in the
english channel it happened yesterday
off the coast of france as mts taeb
shows us the group was traveling from
france to the uk which is a very
dangerous journey of just 21 miles
only the most desperate would be willing
to make this journey as french police
look on men women and children boarding
inflatable dinghies to cross the english
channel
before the bitterness of winter sets in
[Music]
27 people lost their lives making such
an attempt including five women and a
little girl
french lifeboat rescuer charles deval
said
there were bodies floating in the water
it was very shocking to see we recovered
six people
all dead
it was the single biggest loss of
migrant life in what is one of the
world's busiest shipping lanes since
records began in 2014. politicians on
both sides of the channel say people
smugglers are to blame
now is the time for us all to step up to
work together to do everything we can to
break these gangs who are literally
getting away with murder
but migrant rights groups say it's the
french and british governments who
helped create this crisis france for the
brutal conditions in its migrant camps
and britain for the lack of legal routes
for asylum to the uk
pushing the most vulnerable into risking
it all
now five suspected traffickers were
arrested overnight but until britain and
france can come up with meaningful
solutions to this crisis
more will likely lose their lives dana
mts tayab in london thank you